Russian Flags
photos of the Russian president
and children dancing to a patriotic
Russian pop song
these images from Ukrainian schools and
nurseries show the kremlin's efforts to
give children in the occupied
territories a Russian identity the
change that schools are one of the most
obvious simplest forms of rucification
the Wall Street Journal examined videos
and photos shared by Russian authorities
to understand how Moscow is trying to
influence children in the occupied
regions
foreign
Russia has been pushing to incorporate
four partially occupied Ukrainian
regions into its legal social and
economic systems ever since he claimed
to Annex them in 2022
education has been key to these efforts
official posts show children in the
occupied regions learning about the life
of the composer of Russia's national
anthem celebrating Russian science day
enjoying the annex Crimean peninsula in
the colors of the Russian flag they're
pushing a very patriotic pro-russian
curriculum the Wall Street journal's Ian
Lovett spoke with families whose
children attended Russian run schools in
areas retaken by Ukrainian forces as
well as teachers who work there
they told him that schools under
Russia's Administration largely left
Ukraine and its history out of the
curriculum
in the morning at some schools the kids
have to sing the national anthem there's
now classes conducted exclusively in
Russian there is still in some schools
Ukrainian language class but it's now
taught as a foreign language
the journal found this document in a
school in the hakive region outlining
the goals of secondary education one of
them is to form a Russian civic identity
among the students
moscow's efforts to rustify Ukrainian
children but also documented in a report
by the Yale School of Public Health it
accused the Kremlin of relocating
Ukrainian children to Russia and
re-educating them to become pro-russian
following this report the state
department said there was mounting
evidence of the kremlin's aims to deny
and suppress Ukrainian identity history
and culture the schools in occupied
territory also have the goal of turning
them into Russian children I think
they're hoping that in a generation they
won't have as many ukrainians to fight
against
Moscow denied having forcefully
relocated Ukrainian children despite
multiple official images showing
Ukrainian orphans arriving in Russia
the Kremlin also denied having special
programs aimed at the russification of
Ukrainian children and said it creates
opportunities for all children in Russia
to study their native languages
Ukrainian children are not only targets
of Russian propaganda they also became
integral to it as official photos and
videos show schools themselves and the
kids who attend them have been turned
into parts of Russian propaganda which I
think is mostly targeting Russian
citizens inside of Russia with the goal
of showing them that these Ukrainian
regions are eagerly accepting our
Liberation is what they call it here
school children form the shape of a star
and hold Russian Flags to commemorate
the defender of the Fatherland Day a
holiday which celebrates Russia's Armed
Forces
and these are letters children wrote to
Russian soldiers on the front line in
Ukraine
one letter shows a Russian flag and a
tank in which a soldiers health strength
and victories
schools across Russia have placed more
emphasis on patriotic education since
the invasion of Ukraine began
but the consequences for children in
occupied Ukrainian regions could be
far-reaching even if the occupation
doesn't last for forever in some of
these areas if they get six months or a
year or two years with these kids that's
probably going to have a very profound
impact on the way those kids think about
Ukraine and Russia foreign